I'm hoping this video won't take very
long but I just want to mention the
gluconeogenesis allosteric regulation so
pyruvate carboxylase is the first
reaction of gluconeogenesis in which we
take our pyruvate and turned it into
oxaloacetate on its way back to becoming
glucose so this the allosteric activator
of pyruvate carboxylase is acetyl co a
so high levels of acetyl co a activate
pyruvate carboxylase we haven't talked
too much about a syllabic away just yet
but it's actually created from pyruvate
when there's oxygen available so that
acetyl co way can go onto the TCA cycle
and later the electron transport chain
so why would a seat okay or why would
high levels of it activate pyruvate
carboxylase and therefore activate
gluconeogenesis acetyl co a is an
indicator it indicates that the TCA
cycle or the krebs cycle or the citric
acid cycle whatever you want to call it
the TCA cycle and the electron transport
chain again both of these concepts which
we'll talk about later it indicates that
these things are backed up essentially
what's supposed to happen is acetyl co a
supposed to go through the Krebs cycle
or the TCA cycle and eventually the nadh
and fadh2 s that build up coded lechon
transport chain but if there's a bunch
of acetyl co a it is going is is is
built up that probably means that the
TCA cycle is not cycling it all the way
through so they let this the cycle and
the electron transport chain are
probably backed up they're not going as
to completion or they're not you know
finishing up what they're supposed to do
so there's a bunch of uh Co Co way
around there's no sense in making more
right so instead what we would do is we
would activate prior abate carboxylase
which takes pyruvate instead of being a
allowing pyruvate to be converted to
acetyl co a but it is it takes those
pyruvate and converts them into
oxaloacetate on the way back to creating
glucose okay so in this case
want to just go ahead and take those
pyruvate instead of turning them into
acetyl co a we just go backwards in and
convert them into glucoses so we
activate the the process of
gluconeogenesis
now what about fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
ace it has two allosteric inhibitors the
first one being high levels of a MP so
what is high high levels of a MP this is
this indicates low energy at a low
energy state right so we have low energy
then we want to make sure we're making
energy right so virtuous 1-6
bisphosphate ace is involved in
gluconeogenesis right which is the
process that stores glucose right or
reforms glucose instead of breaks it
down for energy so high levels of a MP
what they want is they want they do not
want to be storing glucose they want
glucose is to be broken down so that we
can create ATP so a low energy state
would not favor gluconeogenesis and
therefore inhibit the enzyme that
involved in gluconeogenesis the second
thing is high levels of fructose to 6
bisphosphate
if you recall high levels of fructose to
6 bisphosphate indicate a high
concentration of glucose right so if is
a lot of glucose around then there's no
sense in making more of it right if
there's a bunch of fructose to 6
bisphosphate that means a bunch of
glucose around so we would inhibit the
enzyme involved in the process that
makes more glucose so we don't make more
glucose and if you
chose to 6 bisphosphate is an activator
of PF p FK 1 in glycolysis so here it
inhibits like gluconeogenesis and
activates glycolysis which makes sense
right because you don't want both
processes to be active at the same time
why would you want to break down glucose
and make glucose in the same cell at the
same time that just doesn't make sense
it seems counterproductive now for just
1 6 bisphosphate a's does have an
activator an allosteric activator and
that's high levels of ATP
of course this indicates a high energy
state so if we have a lot of energy
around let's just go ahead and store
energy right so it was we would we would
activate googling adenosine by
activating fructose 1 6 bisphosphate ace
so in this case we're we have plenty of
energy around so store store glucose ok
hopefully that was pretty simple to
follow and hopefully it made sense as
far as why these allosteric effectors do
what they do
thanks for watching